[Music]
at Zone there's a growing appetite for
folks who want to do venture capital and
folks who want to do private equity and
folks who want to do hedge funds so I
came back to teach alternative
Investments the nickname that some of my
students have called it is how to make
crazy cash
the real name is uh how to be a chief
investment officer how do you do a deal
do you how do you buy a company what do
you do when you buy a company how do you
turn it around how do you create a new
Venture how do you think through
management teams uh how do you think the
new products who's your Market who are
your customers
how do you think about Supply chains a
lot of what Frank does is about pulling
other people along with him
recognizing that it takes a village it's
a community just because you've achieved
a certain level of success in one area
doesn't mean that you forget that you
are a part of a larger Collective and
how important it is to give back all the
capital that is being funded towards
these very large Investments and we're
talking hundreds of billions of dollars
uh less than 1.7 goes towards uh female
founded companies
less than 0.7 percent goes towards
African-American founding companies
every year MIT puts on a investment
conference they were trying to find some
interesting speakers and so they came to
me and said would you help us out and I
said sure but
I want to make sure that you're
featuring black women
Asian women uh you know and we went down
the list
having a Auditorium filled with folks
that are seeing successful
African-American women successful Asian
women et cetera et cetera and are all
doing things in the Venture space I
think made a real difference
I see this award
to be received by Frank uh to be
entirely consistent with the vision the
practice the ideas of Dr Martin Luther
King Jr
I think MIT does itself well
by recognizing
Dr Martin Luther King Jr through
the actions and works of front
[Music]